I think we've always you know we've
always had a ambitious approach to it
you know we call it internally as you
know 10x or moonshots we try to work on
things which you know criteria we think
is we want to work on things which
people will use every day it will apply
to billions of people and it solves a
real problem for them so that's the bar
so anything we try to do we we think of
it that way and so we aim high we try to
use deep computer science to anything we
approach so that we can make have a
differentiated approach to solving it
and you know and you want to aim high
enough that you fail you know a few
times I think it's the natural part of
the process in fact you know Larry is to
say if you aim if you work on really
difficult things you're better off
because you have no competition others
aren't working on that difficult of
problem and even if you fail you end up
doing something great in the process you
know I would actually encourage all of
you you know it's at some point in your
life you know you have to work with
people where you feel a bit insecure
that's essential because that means
you're working with people who are
better than you and we're pushing you
right and so always encourage if you if
you actually feel very secure in what
you do you know that means you're doing
something comfortable and you're not
pushing yourself and so there are many
many times have felt working with people
in a group am i doing enough these
people seem much better than me and I
think I think that's a inherent part of
learning you just watch - amazing clips
with sundar Pichai take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]